I'm the youngest certified integrative
nutrition health coach in the country
and the world as far as I know but I
usually don't say that part hi my name
is Hayley Thomas I'm 17 years old a
vegan health activist the CEO of the
happy organization and a total foodie
the healthy eating aspect really came
out of my dad was diagnosed with type
two diabetes when I was about eight and
that's when we really just started
experimenting with healthy foods and
decided to ditch the medication and in a
few years we were actually able to
completely reverse his condition and so
that to me proved the power of food but
also the potential in healthy foods and
eventually becoming vegan so the
inspiration behind the sweet potato
pizza and that I'm making today really
came from just being creative and kind
of playing around I absolutely love
sweet potatoes they're one of my
favorite foods besides avocado nice and
so I really wanted to find a way to get
that sweetness but that hardiness
essentially just being able to take a
core group of ingredients and kind of
swap it out and mix it up and add
different sauces and add different
greens and proteins and things like that
is really fun for me and I enjoy kind of
playing with those combinations and
that's kind of how this pizza was born
my advocacy really started when I was
about ten and saw this evidence of my
dad just getting better and our family
learning so much we're not only one
perspective of food and exercise but
also all the other components of just
life that contribute to health and
well-being and that was really
eye-opening for me and definitely helped
me integrate those aspects into
our nonprofit programs and just an
everyday kind of life for me as well oh
my gosh I love Obama she's amazing and
I'm so incredibly lucky to have met her
six or seven times I am just always so
constantly inspired by her and
everything that she does and everything
that she represents her telling me to
just keep on going and continue to stay
strong and everything that I'm trying to
share because the world really does need
to hear it and that has fueled me
literally for the past six years so I am
so proud to be a black girl in Gen Z
representing food and wellness it's so
important for us to embrace health and
well-being in order for us to all fuel
our dreams and passions and so I am
grateful to be in this space and
grateful to share this message
[Music]
[Music]
you